Salut, on va commencer cette petite série de l'été par une énigme.
Une énigme tranquille que j'aime bien.
C'est l'histoire d'un génie,
d'un génie qui maîtrise pas réellement tous ses pouvoirs.
Donc autour de lui il se passe des choses un peu étranges,
Par exemple : l'autre jour, il était devant sa table à repasser,
parce que, oui, les génies repassent, contrairement à moi
et il repassait une chemise en lin
sauf qu' à un moment donné la chemise s'est transformé en chat
qui est parti en miaulant
vous me direz c'est pas très grave
mais faut savoir que le lendemain le génie sort de chez lui, il ferme la porte
Il longe le mur de sa maison et le mur disparaît
pour à la place, laisser juste un os
Un os de jambe en plus
Et ça, il le maîtrise pas et ça l'agace
Alors pour se changer les idées, il part faire du cheval
il prend la selle, il met la selle sur le cheval
et à la place de la selle apparaît une sorte de gros fromage
Là, on va pas se mentir il commence à être agacé le génie
et il est un peu triste, seul le soir pour dîner en repensant à tout ce qui c'est passé ces 2 derniers jours
Et il se fait du riz
Et au moment de manger le riz, le riz se transforme en...
en quoi?
En quoi se transforme le riz?
Oui c'est ça l'énigme,
il faut trouver quel va être la transformation du riz parce qu'il y a une logique derrière tous ça
et je suis sûr que vous pouvez trouver
Alors au départ, j'hésitais entre vous donner la réponse dans 2 jours à la prochaine vidéo
ou vous donner la réponse maintenant
Je vais vous la donner maintenant mais...
mettez pause pour chercher
ou quitter la vidéo et revenez la voir une fois que vous avez la réponse pour vérifier que c'est bon
ou pour avoir la réponse si vous en avez marre de chercher
En tout cas je compte sur vous pour résister à la tentation de mettre la solution dans les commentaires
ce qui foire tout, au final
Attention, je vous donne la réponse dans 3
Maintenant !
L'assiette de riz va se transformer en bateau
et pour être très précis
Ça va se transformer en ferry
Il y a une logique derrière tout ça
Il y a la logique de la fée
parce que, quand on y réfléchit,
il repassait une chemise en lin
et ça s'est transformé en chat
et le chat c'est un fée-lin (félin)
Ensuite le mur de sa maison c'est transformé en os,
Un os de jambe parce que fée-mur (fémur)
Enfin, je vous ai dit que la selle, c'est transformé en une espèce de fromage
parce que la fée-selle (Faisselle)
Et donc, en toute logique le riz va se transformer en fée-riz (ferry)
Dites moi dans les commentaires si vous aviez trouvé
et vous pouvez aussi proposer des énigmes dans les commentaires
parce que c'est comme ça c'est l'été. On est là pour se marrer pour 30 vidéos
Tous les 2 jours jusqu'au 30 août
N'oubliez pas de liker et de vous abonner
Puis moi je vous donne rendez vous dans 2 jours du coup
pour une autre vidéo. Tchao !